[Musique]
c'est le cas pour moi c'est le coeur ici
de tout ce qu'on fait tout ce qu'on a
fait à mirabel pour pénélope gay
l'ouverture du centre mamika québec il y
a un an à peine est l'aboutissement
d'une vie entière passée a aidé les
siens comment une vie a rassemblé autour
d'elle les autochtones dans le besoin a
tenté de recréer un sentiment de
communauté elle qui en a été privé
enfants la cause de la loi sur les
indiens
ma mère apple doit exclus de la
communauté ilnu de mashteuiatsh au lac
saint jean
parce que sa mère avait marié un métis
pénélope a vécu une enfance isolés et
des racines et de sa culture j'ai avoué
marc allaire pourquoi on a fait revivre
ses amarres à tout savez pourquoi moi
parle pas la langue non plus cette
colère a fini par se transformer en un
véritable moteur de changement aussi de
centre manu coffre en un même lieu une
panoplie de services pour les
autochtones de tous les âges vivant en
milieu urbain mais surtout même qui est
devenu une petite communauté autochtone
à québec
oui c'est son site qu'elle appartenant
recueil de l'amour ma maman c'est la
maman de tout le monde nathalie lucas
gay doit partager sa mère avec bien des
autochtones dans le besoin mais elle le
fait avec plaisir surtout qu'elle voit
pénélope tous les jours depuis 20 ans
tout ce qu'elles entreprennent elles le
font ensemble on devient des modèles
aussi de rassembleuse mai mais c'est ça
c'est génial travail examen mais avant
que tout aille mieux
tout allait mal j'ai eu de la violence
la même heure pendant 1 pour nom de
domaine physique sexuelle
verbal pénélope a subi la violence sous
bien des formes avant de trouver la
force de mettre un terme à une relation
toxique sans repères sans argent avec
quatre enfants à charge
elle tombe dans une spirale destructrice
mais elle réussit finalement à rebondir
elle fait un retour aux études à 37 ans
un travail social et elle prend son
envol la souffrance qu'elle a vécu elle
décide de s'en servir pour aider celles
qui veulent en sortir son premier
objectif offrir un refuge pour les
femmes autochtones en difficulté après
dix ans de démarches et de patience elle
ouvre enfin avec sa fille nathalie la
maison d'hébergement missinak en 2000 je
comprends et détruit tout construisent
s'apprend pas mais ça prend pas un mot
pas rester en mire aujourd'hui pénélope
guy est devenu un véritable modèle pour
ses employés alors aidé beaucoup de vie
puis c'est ça pas de prise qu'à leur
fait pour plusieurs familles c'est une
personne très inspirante qui apporte
vraiment beaucoup d'espoir beaucoup de
femmes à toute la communauté autochtone
qui ne veut pas appris il ya quelques
semaines que l'assemblée nationale lui
rendrait hommage en lui décernant sa
médaille d'honneur une reconnaissance
bienvenu quel thé à partager c'est pas
moi qui apporte le set m'a d'ailleurs
c'est mon monde à moi c'est ce moment kg
et ils savent qu'il va se passer quelque
chose puisque tu es je trouve que c'est
une fierté pour moi
[Musique]
si cet honneur lui confirme que le
chemin parcouru
quoique mouvementée à porter ses fruits
et n'a pas pour autant l'intention de
ralentir la cadence
je pense que c'est important qu'est ce
que je fais puis j'arrêterai pas
l'oublier saut
[Musique]